[Music]
on this wednesday night a covet 19
vaccine no longer
a long shot the uk leads the world
the first to approve the pfizer biontech
vaccine
help is on its way who gets it first how
challenging are the logistics and could
canada be next to give the green light
the crisis inside hospitals how the
virus is hitting health care workers
hard a daughter's powerful message if
we're able to put somebody else's
welfare above ours
just like my dad did every single day of
his life
that's what's going to get us through
the sorrow and suffering over covet 19
and ottawa's broken promise why some
first nations will have to wait even
longer
for clean drinking water
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is the day millions have been waiting
for the united kingdom is the first
country in the world to approve the
pfizer biontech vaccine
for covid19 a vaccine that has been
shown in trials
to be 95 effective the vaccine has been
authorized for emergency use in the uk
the british health secretary says the
first 800 000 doses will be ready to
roll out to the public
starting early next week
this is a monumental step forward
it's no longer if there's going to be a
vaccine it's when
this is a day to remember frankly in a
year to forget
it is a massive breakthrough considering
the world hadn't even heard of covid19 a
year ago
the scientists at pfizer and biontech
did in 10 months what usually takes
10 years millions of doses are already
in ultra-cold storage
in belgium and will be shipped to the uk
in thermal boxes
as early as tomorrow there are huge
logistical challenges though this
vaccine is the one that must be stored
at minus 70 degrees celsius
because of that the uk says the first
vaccinations will take place
in hospitals that have the facilities to
store those vaccines and that means the
most vulnerable
residents in nursing homes will have to
wait this same vaccine is one of four
candidates going through the approval
process here in canada
in a tweet today the federal health
minister called the uk approval
encouraging
paddy haidu says health canada's review
is ongoing and is expected to be
completed
soon we'll get to canada's vaccine plan
in a moment but we begin
in the uk where the biggest immunization
program in history is about to begin
crystal commansing has tonight's top
story
the prime minister who himself almost
died of covid19
is now leading the world down the path
of a mass vaccination program
it is the protection of vaccines that
will ultimately
allow us to reclaim our lives and get
our economy moving again britain granted
the pfizer biontech vaccine
emergency use approval the move follows
months of unimaginable grief the uk
has the highest official death toll in
europe
the safety of the vaccine has been
scrutinized
independently by our commission on human
medicines
and no stone has been left unturned so
absolute confidence
in the safety effectiveness and quality
of the pfizer biontech vaccine next week
around 50 hospital hubs across england
will start offering the vaccine to
the over 80s and to care home
staff and others identified vulnerable
care home residents and staff are a
priority but officials haven't figured
out how to widely distribute the vaccine
which
must be stored at an extreme minus 70
degrees celsius
england's deputy chief medical officer
explained the problem like this
this is a complex product with a very
fragile cold chain it's not a yogurt
that can be taken out of the fridge
and put back in multiple times it's
really tricky to handle
officials say if enough people take the
vaccine
deaths can be prevented and so can
long-term health issues
related to the virus i have high hopes
that the
that eventually the vaccine will make a
a very very significant difference the
way we
we live our we live our lives
vaccinations will start early next week
and continue
for months it's hoped that in time other
vaccines will be approved including
some that don't require ultra cold
storage
making it easier for people to get the
shots
crystal gomanson global news london
canada has pre-ordered 20 million doses
of the pfizer vaccine and it is one of
four vaccine candidates health canada is
reviewing
the approval of the pfizer vaccine is
expected to come around the same time as
the u.s and europe
with government officials insisting that
of course safety is the top priority
as abigail beeman reports there are
questions about how the vaccines will be
rolled out when and if
they are finally approved the leader of
the new democrats is calling for a new
crown corporation to manufacture
vaccines in canada
and in the meantime jug meat singh wants
more details about the plans for
vaccines we'll get that aren't
made here there is no clear plan who is
going to receive the vaccine what
choices is this government going to make
what is a robot going to look like
all these questions are still unanswered
health canada is looking at
four different vaccine candidates
canadians will be covered
on vaccines it's always too slow when
you're not first
it depends how you see it i still think
that it's important to take the time
gary kobinger says being a few weeks or
months behind the uk
won't change much but the microbiologist
who left canada's vaccine task force
over concerns about transparency
says the government could do a better
job of keeping canadians informed
people need to know so that they
understand what the challenges are as
well they can be explained where the
challenges are and they can understand
why things are not happening at the same
speed
at all the locations the bigger the herd
is going to be critical as we sort of
move forward with this
the head of the industry association for
canadian biotech says he's worried about
a challenge
further down the road anti-vaxxers or
vaccine hesitancy
when we get to the point where it is you
know available to everybody but not
everybody's taking it
that's when i think we've got a bit of a
challenge why did this prime minister
cost canadians five months in the
vaccine race
while the opposition leader has been
touting the importance of a vaccine to
combat covid19
one of his caucus members derek sloan
sponsored a petition
questioning vaccine efficacy and safety
claiming
bypassing proper safety protocols means
covid19 vaccination is effectively
human experimentation i haven't read it
since i tabled it there
a couple of weeks back i think there's
some good points in there i'd obviously
have to look at every single point to
tell you if i agree or disagree
the petition so far has 22 thousand
signatures
exposing a divide when science is
leading the federal pandemic response
abigail beeman global news ottawa
if and when canada approves a vaccine
getting it to everyone is going to take
time
and while we wait canadians are still
getting sick and dying
in ontario for the sixth day in a row
more than 1700 new cases of covid19 were
reported and
35 more ontarians died that brings the
death toll in ontario just in the past
seven days to 144.
with case numbers rising fast some
ontario hospitals say
beds are full icus are over capacity and
elective surgeries are being cancelled
despite that the province's health
minister denies there's a crisis
you want to speak about who is in crisis
have you taken a look at alberta where
they're doubling up patients and
intensive care units
we're not doing that in ontario
alberta is dealing with a record surge
in hospitalizations in the last month
the number of covid19 patients there
has more than tripled as of tonight
there are 504 patients
in hospital 97 of them are in intensive
care
alberta premier jason kenney said today
he expects the first doses of the
vaccine will arrive in his province on
january 5th or
possibly before that though of course
nothing has been approved yet
in the meantime his health minister said
there are talks underway about
contingency plans
for tents to house field hospitals
they've begun conversations but this
is not part of our current plans this is
you know conversations about a
contingency plan which health officials
should be doing both those in the
mystery and
those in ahs
and quebec hit a new high for covid19
cases today for the first time that
province is reporting more than 1500
new cases the number of hospitalizations
is also creeping up there are now 740
people in the hospital with covid19 in
quebec
99 in intensive care as mike armstrong
explains it's putting a serious strain
on the health care system
and the people who work in it
there is a number hidden in quebec's new
daily record for covet 19 cases
it's not the total 1 500 that's the
biggest problem
it's how many inside that number are
health care workers
those people cannot take care of other
people and then
everything shuts down and that's the
problem right now quebec has two
thousand beds for covent 19
and less than half of them are being
used the problem is it doesn't have the
staff to care for patients
in those beds part of its protocols a
lot of jobs take more people due to
covet 19
but the biggest issue is staff off work
because they're sick
or as a precaution that's the rule we
don't want to risk having a health care
worker seeing 20 30 patients
infecting all of them according to the
province more than 6 500 health care
workers are off the job that doesn't
include
burnout or people who've simply left the
profession
people at the beginning were going on
adrenaline
eventually the adrenaline runs out
to keep the system going the province
has been canceling vacations and
forcing mandatory overtime for months
the pandemic is taking a toll in
particular on nurses
you know every day they know they're
going to work but they don't know when
they're coming back home
quebec hospitals are actually treating
fewer people than usual at this time of
the year compared to a normal year
about 20 percent less but what has
everyone nervous is whether that stays
the case
covert 19 hospitalizations are growing
quebec started in november with less
than 500 covet 19 patients in hospital
but it's been creeping up ever since as
of tuesday it was
740. i want to tell the truth to the
population
right now the trend is not good the
danger is
what's around the corner if too many
people gather over the holidays there's
fear
an already dire situation could get
even worse mike armstrong global news
montreal the canadian military will not
be heading to a remote first nation in
northern manitoba despite calls from the
community's chief
for their support the situation in
shamatawa first nation about 745
kilometers northeast of winnipeg
is getting worse according to chief eric
redhead he says 76 covid19 cases have
now been confirmed and
100 are expected by saturday the federal
government says a temporary isolation
shelter has been sent to the community
and department officials have been in
contact with leadership in shamattiwa
about concerns around enforcing public
health orders but no military help
has been committed the u.s centers for
disease control and prevention has
issued new guidance about the quarantine
period for people exposed to covet 19.
the cdc now says people could leave
quarantine without taking a test if they
do not develop any symptoms 10 days
after being exposed to someone
with the coronavirus or after seven days
with a negative test result and no
symptoms
research shows most people develop
symptoms four or five days after
exposure
health canada says it is not planning to
change the rules here
canadians still must quarantine or
self-isolate for 14 days
tackling a dual crisis coming up the new
warnings about
how our health care system can't handle
the impact
of climate change
2020 has been all about the coronavirus
but there is a deeper
long-term issue going on the health
impacts of climate change
a new report in the lancet says health
care systems are not prepared for the
increasing threats posed by a warming
planet
a reality researchers call the most
worrying outlook to date
as eric sorenson reports they say the
two global crises pose similar dangers
that should be addressed in tandem
in 2020 climate change was overshadowed
by covet 19
but that has not slowed the relentless
rise in global temperatures
a new lancet study says health systems
are not prepared for the impact a
changing climate will have on both lives
and livelihoods
rising sea levels will displace millions
big cities will bake
wildfires and smoke will damage lungs
drought will destroy
agriculture and excessive heat will take
more lives
we know that when it is extremely hot
people
tend to die more so there is an increase
in
in mortality the lancet study sees
parallel threats from climate change and
covet 19
especially for the elderly in canada
people over 65 account for more than 90
percent of all the covet 19 deaths
since march at the same time people over
65 have seen a 58
increase in heat related deaths in the
last 20 years
climate mortality statistics are more
gradual but just as real
overall more than 12 thousand canadians
have died from covet 19 this year
from climate change in 2018 mortality
from heat
coupled with air pollution death
succeeded eleven thousand
for covet and climate the consequences
are serious
on the economy the pandemic has cost
more than half a million canadian jobs
this year
less visible extreme heat has seen seven
million more lost hours of work each
year compared with 30 years ago
these health impacts are so significant
that it's going to cost more to our
economy
not to address them than if we take the
initiative to address them
in a timely manner now the pandemic
exposed the stress on our health care
systems but provides an opportunity to
get it right for the growing climate
crisis
we can't just tackle one crisis at a
time we need to come together
and address the climate and health
crisis as well the
aim say researchers should be to align a
covid recovery with a green recovery
it's kind of a triple win situation here
we have the potential to
create better public health protect the
environment and have a sustainable
economy one more health warning if we
don't address climate change
a warmer planet will increase the risk
of animal to human disease transmission
in other words pandemics could be more
likely in the future
eric sorensen global news toronto
the captain of a california dive boat
that caught fire and sank in september
of last year was indicted on federal
manslaughter charges today
33 passengers and one crew member died
captain jerry boylan faces
34 counts of what's called siemens
manslaughter
he's accused of failing to follow
well-established safety rules
the tragedy is one of the deadliest
maritime disasters in recent u.s history
those who died were trapped below deck
in a bunk room with no way to escape the
fire that broke out at night
and there was no roving watchman on
board
still ahead how 14 countries including
canada plan to protect the world's
[Music]
oceans
you're watching global national
[Music]
the federal government admitted today it
won't fulfill its election promise first
made in 2015 to get clean drinking water
to all first nations by march
of 2021. indigenous services minister
mark miller says it was an
ambitious deadline and he takes full
responsibility for failing to meet it
he says the pandemic delayed upgrading
some water systems and
limited access to resources the
government has committed another 1.5
billion dollars to tackle the complex
issue but it is no longer promising
when all the water advisories will be
lifted
this isn't a deadline where we'll just
walk away and somehow our consciences
are clear
uh quite the opposite this is a much
deeper commitment to walking
along the path of ensuring that
communities have
safe access to clean and reliable
drinking water
for the long term
97 first nations water advisories have
been lifted since 2015
59 are still in effect and it's expected
at least 22 will remain past
march of 2021. one of the world's most
lucrative fisheries opens this week in
southwest nova scotia
lobster fishers land a huge catch for
export worth
almost three billion dollars a year it's
a reminder how precious
and how resource rich the world's oceans
are
and as ross lord reports canada has now
teamed up with other nations
to protect them the health of oceans has
been declining for decades
from activities like overfishing and
pollution taking what we want
and putting back in what we don't want
in canada research shows only a quarter
of fish stocks is reliably healthy
a new international effort promises to
elevate a healthy ocean from the bottom
of the global policy agenda
to the top through this commitment each
country
will have a sustainable ocean plan
in place by 2025.
the country's promised to improve nearly
30 million square kilometers
of national waters an area the size of
africa
if it happens they say oceans will
produce more food more renewable energy
and ease global warming canada and 13
partner nations have signed on among
those who haven't
is the united states their leader at the
time which was donald trump didn't have
much of an interest in joining this
agenda
maybe under the new administration we do
see a shift in thinking there
the leaders say they're not trying to
divert attention away from urgent
priorities like stopping covet 19
they insist the ocean can bring economic
relief as the world looks to recover
from the pandemic
a statement from prime minister trudeau
reinforces canada's support
but some of the panel's goals are easier
said than done
including making more sections of ocean
off limits to fishing or drilling for
oil and gas
a government that's had trouble meeting
timelines for other commitments
could face a challenge convincing
canadians this promise will stick
ross lord global news
looking beneath the numbers next putting
a human face on the toll of covid 19.
more than twelve thousand canadians have
now died from covet 19 and each day
dozens more
are added to the list there are too many
to name
but we know there are families across
this country who are mourning
tonight heather europe's west has the
story of one of them
we just happened to turn on the evening
news
and my dad's death was being reported
and it you know it was just a man in his
eighties it's how
since the beginning of this pandemic all
deaths have been shared
no names just ages and genders but for
catalan lange
her father yoshif was so much more so
the next day she wrote a post on
facebook
that's now been shared more than two
thousand times
there are so many numbers announced
every day with regards to this pandemic
active cases recovered cases then there
are the numbers that people throw around
about survival rates
well here are a few more 54
the number of years my parents were
married and completely devoted to each
other
when lang moved to clifton manor a
long-term care center down the road last
year
his wife visited twice a day to go and
sit with him and be with him and watch
tv with him
in the spring for three months those
visits were put on pause
clifton manor experienced several
outbreaks but each time
lang avoided infection until a single
case in mid-november
caught fire it took less than a week for
the virus to take his life
by wednesday it was he
he started deteriorating and by
late saturday night early sunday morning
he was gone lang's daughter wanted to
share her family's grief on social media
because
she knows they're not alone there have
been thousands of others
and dozens more each day whose deaths
may be reported as numbers
but to their families they were so much
more so tonight on the news you'll hear
about a man in his 80s who died from
covid
know that he was loved and adored know
that he was the beating heart of my
family
and know that there isn't
a number large enough to accurately sum
up
the loss we feel today yoshiflang
1932 to 2020. heather urex west global
news
calgary
and we know there are so many more that
is global national
for this wednesday i'm donna friesen we
leave you tonight with a countdown to
christmas that's a little bit fishy
these penguins at the london zoo were
pretty excited to get at this advent
calendar designed just for them
i'll stick with chocolate thank you hope
to see you here again tomorrow take care
of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you